seit dieser woche kämpfen das wissen sie
drei prominente cdu politiker um den job
der cdu chefin angela merkel
hkk märz oder sparen es kann nur einen
geben
und das sind nur die prominenten
insgesamt haben sich wohl schon über 20
kandidaten für den parteivorsitz
beworben 20
wahnsinn die spd hat nicht mehr so viele
mitglieder es ist auch und die cdu steht
jetzt vor einer regelrechten mutti
morphosys friedrich merz friedrich merz
ist offensichtlich der liebling vieler
medien warum auch immer
dem mann wird inzwischen alles zugetraut
er führt die union vernichtet die afg
und rettet im vorbeigehen aus versehen
noch die spd ja und diese
erwartungshaltung ist im grunde kein
wunder wenn man bedenkt was der märz in
den letzten zehn jahren alles geleistet
hat
wussten sie zum beispiel es war merz der
obama gesagt hat wo osama bin laden
wohnt hier wirkt dafür bleibe mir putin
mit bloßen händen einen bären 2014 hat
uns natürlich zum weltmeister geschossen
und er besitzt das einzige legale
baumhaus im hambacher forst kurz gesagt
vergiss mutter teresa pose pakistan
stell dich ganz hinter jesus mit dem rc
ja
das steigt herab auf die erde und kehrt
zurück in die politik ist natürlich
blödsinn erklärt zurück in den
sichtbaren teil der politik dritte hat
als lobbyist selbstverständlich politik
gemacht über jahre in aufsichtsräten die
firma blackrock zum beispiel hat ihnen
ja nicht eingekauft weil er so ein
toller geschäftsmann ist oder wegen
seiner schönen haare sondern wegen
seiner kontakte in die politik weil er
die nummer von schäuble hat letztlich
haben die denn eingekauft als lebendes
telefon register ist muss man so hart
sagen ja und das zahlt sich jetzt aus
gleich bei der allerersten
pressekonferenz zu seiner kandidatur
sagt unser kommender herrscher was
blackrock beteiligt an sämtlichen
dax-konzern gerne hört deutschland hat
eine viel zu kleine zahl von aktionären
andere länder sind da viel weiter als
wir und ich möchte auch dazu einen
beitrag leisten das übereinkommen
endlich sagt es mal einer ganz wichtig
was deutschland fehlt sind aktionäre sie
als laien dachten jetzt uns fehlen
lehrer oder pfleger weil sie keine
ahnung haben aber es sind tatsächlich
aktien ist übrigens wirklich kein witz
jetzt eines der wichtigsten ziele von
blackrock dass mehr deutsche in
aktienfonds investieren aber ich sehe da
keinen interessenkonflikt wenn der
friedrich bei kanzler wird oder
klitzekleiner warnhinweis vielleicht
noch von mir über märz im wussten sie
vielleicht gar nicht der job des
cdu-vorsitzenden ist tatsächlich ein
ehrenabend
ja das wort kennt er wahrscheinlich gar
nicht ist schwer zu erklären aber im
prinzip gibt es kein geld
null euro ist allerdings super für die
steuer seine größte konkurrentin heißt
kramp karrenbauer oder wie ihre fans ihn
nennen annegret kramp karrenbauer ja die
machos
annegret kramp karrenbauer
die ollen machos in der union sprechen
wohl heimlich nur noch von der mini
merke ja sie wäre quasi der klon von
merkel
dabei ist ihr gesellschaftsbild viel
konservativer als das der kanzlerin
kaka ist zb strikt dagegen dass schwule
lesben heiraten dürfen nur mal als
beispiel
sowohl die noch mal die arme great im
städtchen püttlingen im saarland und es
hat eine bekannte bürgerinnen jetzt auch
in berlin
die demnächst vielleicht noch ein stück
bekannter wird die hat ja keine zeit
doch wissen wir nicht gesehen hat
vielleicht vor 46 woche was mit ihrem
mann im all die bei all dem was ich
nicht verstehe warum geht man mit
einkaufen aber egal
immerhin hat annegret schon mal eine
wahl gewonnen freunde im gegensatz zu
märz und sparen
und genau das hat sie den beiden alpha
rüden auch recht subtil eingerieben
ich weiß wie man aus einer opposition
heraus wahlen gewinnen kann und wie man
dann diese mehrheiten eben auch gegen
alle widerstände verteidigt klammer auf
das man sind die beiden anderen erstmal
beweisen dass sie das auch können
das liegt in der jeweiligen biografie
hier
eins zu null für ak
ja gut kommt
es waren die kirche im dorf lassen sie
hat im saarland gewonnen
das ist jetzt kein bundesland in dem
sinne mehr so der blinddarm von
rheinland pfalz aber immerhin immerhin
was hat denn je in spanien geworden
immer ja seit seinen wahlkreis im
münsterland 7 wahlberechtigte drei
schafe herzlichen glückwunsch
außerdem ist er hier dem märz natürlich
politisch viel zu ähnlich
wir haben viel zu ähnliche vorstellungen
das wäre ja fast schon tragisch weil ich
mal da kommt endlich seine große stunde
er hat ja ehrgeiz da kommt endlich seine
große stunde
und dann ist er wegen märz vielleicht
auch gleich das sterbende sparen
vielleicht vielleicht meine das
eigentliche casting kommt erst noch
hier demnächst bei prosieben herzlich
willkommen zu schlag den märz hier kommt
kandidat eins der jens ich bin jetzt
sparen 34 jahre alt habe schuhgröße 49
seine hobbys sind schuhe in seiner größe
finden
natürlich jens spahn um sich für schlag
den märz fit zu machen hatte extra einen
sehr schlechten personal trainer
engagiert er ist sich sicher ich schlag
den märz candida zwei wie annegret ich
mache in und für die partei ein angebot
wie ein angebot nach
die sympathische saarländerin aus dem
saarland mit der kurzen kurzhaarfrisur
ihre hobbys sind putzen und das saarland
um sich fit zu machen hat sie extra
einen sehr schlechten luft
gitarrenlehrer engagiert sieht ist sich
sicher ich schlag den märz schlag den
märz die schober der schon feststeht wer
gewinnt der märz
den berg die große frage
wenn er denn der favorit ist wie
spannend wird das rennen um die merkel
thronfolge reden wir drüber mit martin
klempnow er leitet das social media team
für jens spahn erklärte was ist der plan
um sparen zum parteichef zu machen wie
wollen sie den großen favoriten märz
noch ausstechen
absolut du kommst hier heute schon ja
genau beim zdf bei mobilen kanal live
aus der ohne ketten hier mit dem dicken
vecchio swingt mal schickt wir knutschen
mal lieber richtig geil geil schon 3 0
[Gelächter]
ich muss leider schluss machen ja ja ja
und sterben hier die zuschauer will ja
alles klar
ich denke ich das gesehen so gewinnst du
heute waren ja twenty four seven posten
bis der puck fand friedrich merz top
favorit märz ist nicht bei facebook
nicht bei instagram nicht mal bei
kindern
märz alter da kannst du auch gleich den
adenauer wieder ausbuddeln
ich würde aber trotzdem noch mal gerne
auf die inhalte kommt für die jens spahn
steht ja ich würde gerne den geilen film
mal zeigen die mir letzte woche bei
facebook gemacht haben
die cdu ist das herz unserer demokratie
wir haben zugelassen dass dieses herz an
kraft verlieren zwei worte besser kannst
du es nicht machen die ganze zeit diesen
rhythmus und dann werden plötzlich so
worte eingeblendet die in wirklichkeit
absolut nichts bedeuten nicht
fantastisch wird es ist ja genau mein
punkt erklärt nun alles nur phrasen ja
absolut
aber die presse ist ja noch gar nicht
sein ich bin sicher zusammen können wir
wieder stark werden konsequent
entscheiden
keine kompromisse machen bei rechtsstaat
und sicherheit
da hast du doch deine inhalte hashtag
sparen fast alles zusammen wofür sparen
steht spahn halt und diese geste wir so
rapp mäßig die arme hochreißt das kann
der märz gar nicht mehr wer arthrose
moment mal so wie der film aussieht habt
ihr denn noch nicht letzte woche gedreht
der liegt garantiert schon monate war
ich in der schublade
was solche spots bastelt die heute jeder
14 jährige förderschüler nebenbei beim
kacken ihr ich hab dich eben gerade
backstage gefilmt und direkt auf meinem
handy geschnitten guck mal
olli back ist das paar kalte herz des
zdf vor jeder show schneidet er sich die
nasenhaare guck mal die untere hälfte
von seinem gesicht laber die obere
kannst du eh nicht zeigen die heute
schon per steckdose mittel aber was wir
sonst gucken
jens spahn
[Applaus]
[Musik]